economía en france 24 en el estudio
daniel hablando con daniela buena noche
bienvenida reino unido y bruselas entra
en una semana crucial para el brest hola
buenas noches sin acuerdo todavía los
líderes de la unión europea y el reino
unido- ursula von der leyen y boris
johnson respectivamente quedaron de
encontrarse cara a cara en los próximos
días para poder dirimir las diferencias
que persisten de cara a un acuerdo
comercial si no lo hay raúl ambos
perderán beneficios sobre todo
arancelarios a partir del primero de
enero del próximo año pero también hay
varios análisis de lo que podría ser el
impacto potencial de un break sheet sin
acuerdo
por ejemplo la oficina de
responsabilidad presupuestaria de gran
bretaña estima que esta nación tendría
dos puntos menos de crecimiento en 2021
por su parte una investigación de la
aseguradora allianz dice que una salida
desordenada podría costarle a la unión
europea unos 33 mil millones de euros
anuales en exportaciones y en esa misma
línea a otro estudio de help
search asegura que el bloque perdería
unos 700 mil puestos de trabajo continúa
entonces la novela en torno a este break
si del impuesto a las grandes fortunas
daniela es casi una realidad en
argentina sin haber solamente le falta
la firma de el presidente fernández el
proyecto ya pasó la prueba en la cámara
de diputados y luego en senado después
del agrio debate tras el rechazo de la
oposición ahora espera la firma del
mandatario quien fue el que lo promovió
este es un gravamen único y
extraordinario que van a pagar quienes
tengan un patrimonio de más de 200
millones de pesos es decir unos 2.5
millones de dólares el impuesto va desde
un 2 por ciento y va subiendo hasta un
3,5 por ciento a medida que el
patrimonio sea mayor en un principio la
administración federal de ingresos
públicos creía que iba a cobijar a unas
9 mil personas pero como el peso se ha
venido devaluando tanto ahora se estima
que serán casi 12 mil personas y el
recaudo estimado es unos 3.675 millones
de dólares
que serán usados para atender la crisis
sanitaria donde vamos hasta méxico
porque el país en una nueva secretaria
de economía si raúl en medio de un
remezón en su gabinete ministerial con
cinco nuevos integrantes
el presidente de méxico nombró en la
secretaria económica a la diputada
tatiana clouthier quien tiene un perfil
más político que técnico ella fue su
jefe de campaña y tiene fama de muy
buena negociadora por lo que ahora será
una ficha clave para tratar de reparar
esos lazos bastante rotos con los
empresarios también para recuperar la
maltrecha economía que ya venía en
recesión desde antes de la crisis de el
coronavirus este profundo cambio
ministerial protagonizado por mujeres
será justo días después de que alfonso
romo renunciara como jefe del gabinete
de lópez obrador y también hablando de
diversidad danielle en las puestas de
nueva york se busca implementar esta
diversidad en las juntas directivas
cerrado el mire qué interesante sólo va
a hacer nada
qué es la plataforma que aglutina a las
empresas tecnológicas listadas en la
bolsa de nueva york como por ejemplo
facebook twitter apple o amazon entre
otras pues le pidió autorización a la
comisión de valores para implementar
nuevas reglas para la composición de las
juntas directivas
en concreto se busca que cada junta
directiva tenga al menos una mujer y un
miembro de alguna minoría que puede ser
afrodescendiente o lg y entre otras y si
no los tienen deben explicar por qué no
los tienen habrá ciertas excepciones
como empresas extranjeras o las que son
muy pequeñas que pueden suplir esa
condición con dos mujeres en su junta se
busca promover la igualdad y que cada
una haya al menos dos miembros de estas
comunidades así desde los indicadores
bueno pues el nasdaq fue el único índice
que subió en la bolsa de nueva york y de
paso marcó un nuevo récord mientras
tanto en el 'viejo continente' las
fallidas negociaciones del break sit
arrastraron las bolsas aunque
paradójicamente londres si subió en
américa latina hubo ligeras pérdidas con
excepción de colombia que repuntó casi
un 2%
para finalizar que no será ahora
entonces como la cifra el día son unos
2.500 millones de dólares que pide
unicef a los gobiernos para invertir en
asistencia de emergencia para el medio
oriente y áfrica del norte estas
regiones están especialmente afectadas
por conflictos desastres y ahora el
coronavirus así en el entonces esperemos
que lo puedan recaudar sin ningún
problema muchísimas gracias como siempre
por toda la información económica a
ustedes también gracias por estar
siempre conectados en nuestra pantalla
esto es france24
[Música]